[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump couldn't make a deal on
health care but Michael Flynn might have
made a deal with the FBI the rushes
story continues to grow grimmer and
bigger and deadlier like a funnel cloud
moving like a living thing out at the
horizon the word treason has been
invoked now by the unlikeliest of
sources by process of elimination it
seems as if flynn or somebody else from
the Trump gang may be ready to testify
against the rest of them the white house
seems to be setting up Flynn and maybe a
second guy as its scapegoats and the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee has been engulfed in a full
week-long spasm of panic part by part
that's a hell of a statement
I couldn't just make that statement even
just as commentary but that was one
man's comment when he retweeted the
McClatchy news report that FBI
investigators probing Russian sabotage
of the presidential election we're now
looking to see if Breitbart Infowars and
maybe other American right-wing sites
were knowingly involved in Russian cyber
operations quote FBI uncovering evidence
of treason there is no other word for it
who wrote that Professor Richard W
painter of the University of Minnesota
law school who from February 2005 until
July 2007 was president george w bush's
chief ethics lawyer
he uses the word quote treason unquote
he also used it six other times like
after the CNN report that the FBI is
culling through evidence that Trump
Associates communicated with suspected
Russian operatives to possibly
coordinate the leaks damaging to the
Clinton campaign or Friday after a
different Politico article despite
mounting evidence of collusion and
treason President Trump is still
spouting the Kremlin line so to cite the
full quote from the 16th century British
courtier and author John Harrington
treason doth never prosper what's the
reason why if it prospers none dare call
it treason none dare call it treason
except the ethics lawyer for president
george w bush
so you are probably okay using the term
so there's a good chance you may have
committed some light treason what should
you do now - once again paraphrase the
former NSA and Naval War College figure
John Schindler first ones to make a deal
usually get the lightest prison
sentences Friday security expert Harvard
lecturer somebody I was proud to help
bring to MSNBC Juliet km put together
three mildly interesting facts and
realized that one other name was missing
and that name and why it was missing was
way more interesting
former Trump campaign manager Paul
Manafort volunteered for a limited
interview with the House Intelligence
Committee and said he talked to the
Senate Intelligence Committee to
longtime Trump's stooge Roger stone
demanded to make an appearance before
the House Intelligence Committee
the second man every name by Trump is a
foreign policy advisor Carter page also
said he would talk to the House
Intelligence Committee Monday morning
the New York Times revealed Jared
Kushner whose best-known skill is that
he has survived being Trump's son-in-law
has been asked to testify to the Senate
Intelligence Committee but is juliek I
am realized the other key actor in
whatever the Trump Russia dance of
deceit really is he hasn't said boo
about testifying anywhere General
Michael Flynn thus says Juliet the
question in the intelligence and
security circles in which she travels is
increasingly becoming could Flynn be
cutting a deal with the FBI Flynn of
course was briefly the national security
adviser until it turned out not only
that so many wild reports about him and
foreign governments were true but that
some of them were sanitized versions of
true but then it turned out he was also
on the Trump campaign team and the
Turkish payrolls simultaneously and now
the former CIA director james Woolsey
says he was at a meeting last summer at
which Flynn on the Trump campaign team
talked to Turkish officials about
returning to Turkish custody the muslim
cleric on whom the turkish dictator
erawan has blamed all his country's
problems and you can translate that
statement as kidnap a legal resident of
the United States from his home in
Pennsylvania
and then take him to imprisonment and/or
death in Turkey making a deal to flip
and tell all he knows about Trump or
whoever might be Flynn's only way out
now since he could be charged with some
traitorous offenses involving two
different foreign countries his reaction
to the story that he might have made a
deal his spokesman told a reporter Flynn
is not quote responding as Humphrey
Bogart who'd to Mary Astor in The
Maltese Falcon don't be Shelly you're
taking the fall funny that Juliet
Cayenne would wonder whether Mike Flynn
may have made a deal with the FBI scene
this blood-curdling cover of the Trump
friendly tabloid the National Enquirer
Trump catches Russia's White House spy
how he tricked the bungling FBI 23
agents have infiltrated Congress federal
bureaus in the military spoiler alert
they mean General Michael Flynn but
there are plenty of buses under which
plenty of the Trump Putin Easter's can
be successfully thrown The Associated
Press story that Paul Manafort signed a
10 million dollar contract in 2006 with
a Russian oligarch the deal Manafort
said would quote greatly benefit the
Putin government the Trump government
had already been distancing itself from
Manta Ford downplaying his efforts with
the campaign saying he was somebody who
played a very limited role for a very
limited amount of time as somebody only
there to count delegates Paul Manafort
was Donald Trump's second campaign
manager all that is missing for Paul
Manafort now is the bus and remember
what mom always said never run for the
bus there will always be another one and
lastly in American politics we have seen
guilty suspects panic and innocent
suspects panic and vindicated suspects
panic but not since ken starr have we
seen somebody who is in effect the
prosecutor panic Devan noonish chairman
of the House Intelligence Committee is
acting like a guy who is about to flee
the country he told the media he had
some kind of intelligence information
that somehow backstopped Trump's
wiretapping hoax and he possibly
violated the law just by saying that to
the
Media he then took that information to
Trump like a prosecutor handing over
evidence to a defendant or at least the
associate of a defendant possibly
violating the law again he explained he
did this amazingly stupid thing because
Trump had been quote taking a lot of
heat in the media he did this before
sharing any of whatever the Intel was
with the rest of his own committee he
had to apologize to his own committee he
then was unable or unwilling to deny
that this information that supposedly
supported Trump originated with Trump
and then The Daily Beast quoted three
unnamed committee officials and a former
national security official who said that
the night before all this started
newness was in an uber with a staffer he
got a call or a text or an email and
immediately bolted out of the car and
though he later denied going missing for
hours it seemed nobody knew where he was
and Monday morning it was reported
newness was at the White House that day
to meet his Intel source but his
spokesman said that while yes he was on
the White House grounds he didn't go to
the White House itself because this is
what happens when you elect Inspector
Clouseau to Congress this is the man
nominally leading the congressional
investigation of Trump and Russia who of
course was also a member of Trump's
presidential transition team and just
happened to be at one of general Flynn's
meetings with the Turkish Foreign
Minister and all this unfolds while my
friend Andrew Mitchell reported quote a
lot of former transition team members in
and outside of the White House now
purging their private phones and while
the Russian propaganda websites Sputnik
may wind up getting press credentials as
part of the Foreign Press covering our
White House this is not blowing over
this has not stopped expanding this is
not something for which we cannot use
the big words this is about whether or
not the man elected president is loyal
to the United States of America or
whether he is instead loyal to the
Russian Federation this is about to
quote george w bush's own White House
ethics lawyer to quote him each of the
seven times he has used the
word it is about treason treason treason
treason treason treason and treason
resist peace